gallery owner Misha LK Vinick has
arrived he's just moved his entire
gallery from cologne to Berlin it's a
big step for him his artwork is being
kept in temporary storage here the car
to its work by South Korean artist
kimsooja it's off a mine off the car
stands for the hopes which I have in
this city and I'm very glad that the
artist made the car available for my
journey so to speak if you might have
eyes it's a fabulous day at work is
still very much underway here at his new
gallery in the historical hapa Palais in
Berlin's Mitte district it's set to open
later this year
kevin ik takes another look through the
rooms that will soon be the venue for
his art it's a bold investment in the
future and a sign of faith in Berlin I
think that Berlin is one of the most
creative places in the world at the
moment it might not be Hong Kong or
Singapore in terms of the concentration
of money but money can take the Express
passing through Berlin it doesn't stop
here occasionally courts and often
tightening this unassuming Street is
packed with galleries it's a magnet for
rich international art collectors and
artists alike Berlin has outrange New
York Berlin is the preeminent location
for galleries and art that means artists
have to have had an exhibition here with
more than its fair share of galleries
Auguste rasa in central Berlin is also a
key address Michele Fuchs found a
special place to exhibit art this former
Jewish school for girls
around three hundred pupils attended
lessons here until it was shut down by
the Nazis in 1942 this seems to be the
school hall it's seven meters high so
the room is very well lit it's a very
attractive space these pictures are by
andreas Golda he's one of a small group
of artists whose work the gallery often
exhibits and this is the artist at work
in his studio in outlying district of
Berlin Golder was born in Russia he came
to study in the German capital and ended
up staying of course one is influenced
by the city I don't paint the TV tower
or courtyard scenes like Atilla did but
when you walk through the city you see
various shades of color and that
inevitably turns up in my work Calder
has already had several exhibitions in
other European cities but his artwork is
especially sought-after in Berlin
so what draws artists here from all over
the world
basically Berlin was able to revive its
creative tradition after the fall of the
wall with their policy of destroying
arts the Nazis had caused a hemorrhage
of Berlin's creative energy that
returned after the wall came down come
that's Heidi that's one of the city's
best-known galleries is igan and art it
has just reopened after extensive
renovation work owner GERD Harry Lipka
came to Berlin from Leipzig more than 20
years ago he's one of the most
successful figures in the Berlin art
scene the difficult thing isn't being
successful it's maintaining momentum
when you've been in the business as long
as we have then you have to know how to
keep that momentum going that's the most
difficult thing for everyone and we've
managed it so far and we're quite alone
out there with that success ljubka
success and that of the other galleries
add to the importance of Berlin as an
art capital and all the signs are there
that the creative energy of the city's
artists and gallerist is a long way from
running out
you